- We are here with America's sweetheart,
and someone who just is the coolest person
on the planet, Jennifer Aniston.
(audience cheering)
You know "The Morning Show."
- Yes.
(audience cheering)
- What are you channeling in that
because it's the greatest
thing I've ever seen
as an actress and in your body of work?
- It was basically about
just revisiting some
of the shadows, blind spots that I'd put
into a particular file,
and meeting them head on,
and actually releasing them.
It was like an extraordinary therapy.
Better than any actual therapist
that I've been going to
for years on end 'cause.
- Do you think that Alex Levy
is the closest character to you
or that you've blessed it
with some of your deepest
truths behind her?
- I think it's a little bit of both.
Alex Levy is people,
someone maybe in particular
who I have witnessed in my life.
People, say a combination of
people who I have watched,
and remember thinking I
don't wanna ever do that.
I don't wanna be that.
Then there is sort of
the tapping into the part
that wants to have that
scream into your pillow
and yell, which I never was able to do
until I did it in front
of 150 crew members.
- [Drew] Because you
wouldn't let yourself?
- I wouldn't let myself.
I didn't know how to, I
like to discuss things,
I like to have a conversation,
a rational conversation
'cause if you're ever with
someone who's a screamer,
nothing gets done.
I just just go shut down,
shut down, shut down.
- What was it about
this point in your life
that you were like I've,
was it an I have nothing to lose?
- It's written, it was written for me,
it was written for me, it was written,
we talked about it.
There's a part as you get older
that you just hit a wonderful
who gives a rat's (beep).
This is just my warmup.
(audience clapping)
It's true.
Right?
- Yes.
I thank you for sharing
that with the world
because it's cathartic for us watching it.
- Thank you.
- I'm serious.
- I just marvel, I marvel,
I marvel, I marvel.
- I can't wait to do a
comedy, let me tell you that.
Rush me to a comedy immediately
after completing that second season.
- I mean, now, when I think of hair,
obviously you're the most
famous head of hair we've got.
Seriously.
- Sad.
- Come on, the Rachel, hello?
(audience cheering)
So when I hear that
you're doing hair care,
I'm like give it to me now.
I'm on the feeder.
Tell me about LolaVie.
- It comes out of many years
of having really unruly hair.
That's always been my struggle.
I paired myself with
these wonderful people
that used to be part of Arden,
and maybe five years ago,
we started working on this,
and we're doing one product at a time
because it has to be perfect.
And that was the first one we started
'cause I live for a good detangler
'cause you rip through your hair
when it's wet, it's half the damage.
- I heard a hot tip.
When your hair is wet,
use a wide tooth comb
because your follicle
is at its most fragile.
- Yes.
- Please do not use a brush
and break through it.
- Especially a really
bristly brush is death.
Or there's actually wet brushes
that are made for wet hair.
- I do love that wet brush.
- I love a wet brush.
I just discovered it.
- Oh my God, I have minis for my kids.
They're all over the house.
- There are minis?
- Yes, you can travel with them.
- Oh God.
- I'm gonna get you so many wet brushes,
you're not gonna believe.
- I'm just not gonna know
what to do with myself.
(upbeat music)